a lot of people back five six years ago
like you don't even use headphones like
you're not a real DJ yeah maybe I don't
know I don't think there's a need to use
headphones if you if you're well
prepared
[Music]
I think the nature of a DJ is to go out
there play song look at the crowd feel
it out and then play whatever you think
people want to hear that's very
different for me because I see myself as
a musician in first place and I think
you name any artist you want I don't
think they go on stage look at the crowd
and say maybe let's play this song I
don't think people like that one you
present the show you prepare you
rehearse for weeks and then this is what
you present to the crowd and there's
always a section that is staying
flexible changing stuff up if you have
to or if you want to but I would say the
majority of my set is pre-planned it's a
show that I want to present I want
people to see something that I spend a
lot of time working on
[Applause]
my live show is not a DJ show at all my
platform is DJing but essentially what's
most important for me is for the crowd
to go home and think that that was an
incredible experience and that they
can't get that same experience from
anybody else that involves of course the
music choice but also the visuals you
see the lights you see the lasers the
special effects and that's all very
choreographed and it's still all made
live there's a cable running from my
computer to front of house with three
screens so everybody is always aware of
what I'm playing and if I decide to
change something last minute every song
that I have ever played has a specific
visual that goes with the song and my
team can in real time see what I'm about
to play and adjust and create the
visuals and the lighting looks and the
colors that we rehearsed for each song
I've had a conversation with a amazing
DJ one of the best DJs he was under the
impression that it's not real DJing if
you go out there and you overlay
something prepared and you have a list
that you plan on playing to me that may
be true for DJ but I just don't consider
myself a DJ I see myself as an artist
who presents a show to me there's
nothing embarrassing about being
perfectly prepared and knowing exactly
what you're about to do but I think that
most DJ's have an issue with that and I
was the one of the DJ's who live often
times didn't even use headphones because
I was so well prepared I knew exactly
what key was going into the other song I
there was no chance at with clashing
because I know what they sound like
I see my show it's almost like you go to
the movies you're not gonna buy your
ticket and see a movie and if you don't
like it you expect the movie to change
in real time I spent way too much time
creating a theatrical show to then
adjust it on the spot and make it
something that's not perfect so when
people go to a show they should expect a
real you know experience not just me
deciding on the flight
[Music]
[Applause]